[Music]
6 24 in your monday morning what's
driving you crazy well say goodbye to
part of range road up in the far
northeast valley now this is a pretty
small section of range road it's right
there between the east and westbound
lanes of the northern 215 beltway
but that's right smack dab in the middle
of what mr langler and i have agreed
could be called
the speedway bowl you know where the
i-15 meets the northern 215. well the
nevada department of transportation says
the closure that started just a couple
of minutes ago
is needed to accommodate construction of
a real line centennial parkway
besides all of the freeway work we
mentioned in the past ndot says this
project will extend
tropical parkway up to centennial
parkway which will replace
range road as the east-west surface
connection eventually there will be a
new eastbound 215 beltway off-ramp to
the new centennial parkway and range
road intersection
however full access to the real line
centennial parkway may not be restored
until early 2022.
all of this information and a whole lot
more on our website eight newsnow dot
com you click traffic then driving you
crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone if there's something driving you
crazy email me
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com